and first up this morning the fight
against biden's radical agenda with
florida taking a lead on a multi-state
lawsuit
against the administration over the mass
release of criminal
aliens by ice this just one of several
important actions governor ron desantis
has taken
on immigration on april first the
governor directed florida state agencies
to identify criminal migrants
in prison and transfer them to ice
custody when their prison term is
complete
in 2019 he signed one of the strictest
bans against sanctuary cities in the
country
florida governor ron desantis joins me
right now governor it's great to have
you this morning thanks very much for
being here good morning to you
good morning to you maria walk us
through this lawsuit against the
administration
on ice
well it's it's this is a reckless policy
that we're opposing here
uh normally when we'd have a criminal
alien convicted of a felony
they obviously served their sentence in
florida state prison and prior to joe
biden's administration
uh ice would would take control of them
when they finished their sentence and
they'd remove the criminal alien
and send them back to their home country
that should be like clockwork that is
the biggest no-brainer there is instead
under biden's administration
they're no longer honoring these ice
detainers they're withdrawing the
detainers
so you have a criminal alien that is
convicted maybe they serve five years in
state prison for a serious felony
ice is effectively releasing them back
in to our communities and and we know
that some of those people will reoffend
we also know that any additional offense
is by definition something
that could have been prevented had they
just followed the law so the lawsuit
seeks to have them actually follow the
law follow the constitution maria you'll
hear
excuses for why they don't enforce
immigration laws in certain instances oh
prosecutorial discretion focus on
on the most threats these are the most
threatening folks
they are criminal convicted aliens and
they're not even doing that
so you can't just totally default on
your responsibility
to enforce the law under the
constitution well
part of it is this dismantling of the
immigration infrastructure
right i mean ice has been effectively
shut down tell me about that
because i don't think that there is more
funding coming
toward these agencies even though the
flows of people are just getting longer
and longer and higher
well you're right i mean it starts with
of course him dismantling president
trump's policies uh to stop the flow of
the illegal migrants across the southern
border
what donald trump did worked it was
working
joe biden dismantled that and now you
have a huge catastrophe at the southern
border and of course that's going to
have
reverberations all across our country so
i think from really top to bottom
they failed biden has failed on on
dealing with illegal immigration and
rule of law
and unfortunately maria when you talk
about the issues of releasing
convicted criminal aliens in the into
american communities
uh there's unfortunately going to be
additional victims and
and that is just totally unacceptable
yeah we're going to talk with stephen
miller coming up about this apparently
the biden administration is flying
migrants across the country to whatever
city
they they would like to go to the city
of their destination choice
uh your thoughts on the sanctuary cities
and and they're they're flying these
people without ids we really don't know
who they are
well just think about it i mean you have
some of these folks the same type of
people
that want the rest of us to have to show
a vaccine passport
just to be able to go to a movie theater
or a ball game yet they're totally fine
with people with no identification
of course no covid testing getting on
airplanes which you and i wouldn't be
able to do without an id
and being able to fly around it's really
really curious that that would be
the decision that they would make but
these sanctuary jurisdictions
are likely where they would end up going
anyways you know florida we banned the
sanctuary cities
it was the right thing to do so i think
when folks
come illegally you know they tend to
gravitate towards some of those
left-wing sanctuary jurisdictions
because they know they basically will
get off scot-free if they're in a
sanctuary city